how did you go about developing these
vampire characters
i kind of have parts of myself and all
of them
uh like you know vania the year
you know his performance as europe he
brought to a whole other level
but there's that part of me that's just
impulsive
and very much about like just
living in the moment um doing things you
regret
not understanding why you know you have
you're perceived a certain way all that
sort of stuff
um daria's character again deal with a
lot of that deal with
you know kind of my own like
self-repression
uh as well so it's a lot like in a way
there's so much of me
and all the characters uh
and that's i think that's just essential
it's like there's a
line that's told to every writer and
it's a dangerous one where they say
write what you know and too
oftentimes i find that makes writers
kind of go with most obvious like well
i await tables so my character is going
to be a waiter who wants to be a
filmmaker
it's like no not necessarily that but
put what you know into your characters
like create something fantastical if you
want
but put yourself into those characters
put people that you know into those
characters so that way when you're
writing them they feel authentic they
feel real
um especially for for myself like
who who needs to see another movie about
some
average white guy who wants to get the
girl and
you know ends up succeeding in the end
or not or whatever it's like
that story's been told 100 times i don't
even want to watch a movie about my life
so in terms of that like being able to
find something interesting about the
life i've had about my own persona and
put that into my characters
and then you know then from there just
have fun with it okay here's my
character
now set them free what are they gonna do
once they're out in the world
um you know what's yuri gonna do when
he's in a
he's in a in an uber ride chair and
some drunk people get in next to him and
they're obnoxious
me i would be quiet and ignore them
his character he's a beast and he's a
vampire so he kills them
um then he feels bad for the driver
who's now stuck in the situation
and now how does he handle that well you
know and so
just kind of for me it's like i like to
create the characters put them in a
scenario and see where they go
what are your thoughts on writing a
protagonist that's a villain
uh i mean i really feel like any
protagonist if they're authentic
is also going to be a villain
everybody's got that side to him
and i hopefully i'm not just projecting
myself out there by saying that uh
but to me it's not a
i don't i don't even like the idea of
having villains
having like protagonist antagonists
because
it's really it's all about perspective
you know you flip the lens around
and you know the bad guy is actually
he's doing what he feels is the right
thing to do in his mind he's justified
it's why
you know you go back in history you look
at nazi propaganda films
they didn't shoot them intending hitler
to look like the villain
but us looking back at it now it's very
iconic villain imagery you see it in the
new star wars films you see
in so many movies they take that imagery
and they flip it around that was
obviously not
the intent of those films and so any
character
if you write a really fleshed out
character i mean
even on i mean the nazi thing is a big
scale on a personal scale we've all been
in relationships
you've had a fight with your significant
other you know you're right
until a certain part of the argument
where you're like oh no you just made a
really good point no okay
i'm in the wrong on that so even in that
argument like you went into it
you were the hero and then you ended
with like oh now i'm the villain
uh so that's how i approach my
characters
is not thinking who's the good guy who's
the bad guy
who's the you know who's the one i'm
rooting for
uh in the end it's just let's get to
know them let's see who they are
and let the audience decide who they
think is like one of my favorite things
and i don't want to spoil too much
for those who haven't seen it but one of
my favorite things is
daria's character she starts out she's
very much the damsel in distress type of
trope she's
you know the ex-girlfriend escaped an
abusive relationship
she's with the sky that we've all seen
him be a monster
and then the story makes a turn and you
start realizing
she's not as helpless as i thought she
was how much of a victim is she really
and then you see that she's even
reconciling that of who she wants to be
versus who she is and to me that's so
much more interesting than being oh
she's good and he's bad
uh i just i feel like that's where so
many movies become
so cookie cutter and so boring is when
it's so obvious
who who's who in the film
by i want it to be by the end of the
film you're still trying to figure out
wait who was i supposed to be rooting
for like i'm happy how i ended but why
am i happy they were terrible
or um you know kind of wanting to know
more like if i feel like if a movie ends
and you're you're trying to peace out in
your mind
where this character went and what they
did and you're still thinking about
the decisions they made then that's
that's a successful film because it
makes you feel like that world was real
and you cared about those characters you
found them interesting enough to
contemplate
you